many kilometers
beneath the moon's surface all
is silent without liquid water
or plate tectonics the quiet is broken
only every so often
by a tremulous rumble for the best part
of 700 million years
since formation in the fires of
planetary collision
little has changed this slice of the
moon's crust
has laying dormant until now
with the power of more than 10 billion
nuclear bombs
its safe haven is atomized in seconds
and it finds itself flung up
into the maelstrom yet again the surface
of its old home
devastated in retreating from its vision
is sloshing about
in towering dusty breakers
the moon has suffered a massive impact
the new traveler arcs effortlessly
across the sky
accompanied by a tsunami of ejected
material
a diaspora beneath the surface of the
moon
scans past it is grey
and cratered and dead
the gale of displaced rock lands like a
plague
all at once and suffocating fusing
together into one solid mass of stone
on the monochrome plane from its new
vantage point
on the exposed surface the recent
arrival
watches its new neighbor it
is also under siege
disparate craters splash mata across the
young earth's chaotic exterior
it whips around with impatient futility
immobile defenseless
against the bruising circles appearing
again and again
on the surface as millennia pass
earth changes color periodically reds
turn to blacks blues sprout rushes of
green
ice comes and goes the circles of
destruction
still appearing on occasion
mostly though it just shrinks
it has been retreating for and so is
very small
now but recently
something very odd has occurred
it has blossomed only visible when the
earth is black
tiny lights have begun to pepper the
planet spreading in white veins across
its surface
and this is when after four billion
years of detached
lonely observation our traveler
is finally met by another forward coming
down nicely 200 feet
four and a half down five and a half
[Music]
back on earth the myriad lunar samples
from the apollo missions
were carefully studied for the first
and to date only time scientists had
access to mata
harvested directly from another world
with so many mysteries to unravel
answers were now potentially within
reach
and to the delight of earth's scientific
community this newfound data converged
upon an insoluble truth
gouged upon the lunar tissue rested the
scars
of a tremendous calamity inside the
materials
atoms providing substance form and
identity had been shocked into a
heightened
alignment crushing pressures had coerced
the rock
into metamorphosis and armageddon
was fossilized on the moon
but of course evidence of stellar
impacts
had been expected galileo galilei first
recognized the lunar craters back in
1609
and in preparation for their missions
apollo astronauts were trained to spot
the signs
of impact looking at the moon through a
telescope reveals
gaping excavations hundreds of
kilometers across
and bands of wreckage slung even further
explosions that punctured deep leaving
pools of magma
to burble in truth evidence of
massive impacts surprised few
what shocked the world was the age of
that evidence
locked inside metamorphosed minerals and
inside the rocks
liquefied by each kilometer strike
lingered atoms
edging towards disintegration by
measuring and comparing these unstable
elements and their offspring
samples from the imbrium crater the
highlands the
sea of serenity samples collected a
thousand kilometers apart or more
we acquired an age the same age
over and over 3.9 billion
years old what catastrophe could have so
traumatically reshaped the moon
not a single impact but a throng a flood
a
bombardment each diving body dozens of
kilometers across
but if a swarm of celestial invaders
assaulted the moon
what then if it's more massive partner
what happened to the earth
modelling and the geological record show
that for every collision suffered by the
moon
the earth endures 20 of its own
such a disaster would have remade our
planet momentously diverting it to a new
evolution
whatever traumatic effect this cataclysm
had upon the earth 3.9 billion years ago
its earthly evidence has long since been
buried
eroded melted and dissolved
if we want to know what happened on our
planet 3.9 billion years ago
we must look towards the rest of the
solar system
for five decades experts have scoured
their imaginations and scientific data
for the origins of this catastrophe did
a fifth
terrestrial planet disintegrate spraying
its minerals across the solar
neighborhood
did a clash near mars divert a string of
projectiles in our direction
many different causes were proposed but
scientists settled upon
one main hypothesis if jupiter's orbit
was altered due to some catastrophe in
the outer disk
then a rabble of remnants from the early
days of accretion
could have been ousted from their homes
and condemned to a brief and desperate
exodus
if this dissent did take place then
evidence is just as likely to be found
on our neighbors as on our earth
the baked surface of mercury is pocked
by a graveyard the same travelers that
scarred the moon
also dug great graves on mercury and
mercury
buried them in magma when the largest
meteors crushed into the feeble surface
they thrust and hurled enormous masses
of stone away
from their resting place leaving
punctures in the crust
hundreds of kilometers across into these
gouges
rushed the pressurized mantle
superheated and relieved of its
confinement
the surging mantle melted and exuded
through
vast vents on the surface layer upon
layer
of hardened magma built until the
cavities were filled
with kilometres of basalt the most
destructive meteors to strike mercury
didn't just melt the crust but
jump-started an era of regional
volcanism
that shaped the planet over hundreds of
millions of years
the moon too was likely provoked into
volcanism by its bombardment
thus producing its famous seas
at the imbrium basin the elected landing
site of apollos 14 and 15
a hardened ocean of basalt swamps the
crater
drowning a ring of islands denoting the
crater's rim
immense fields of basaltic flows
would have dominated the earth's surface
two
seventy to one hundred percent of it
smothered by this blanket of igneous
rock
beneath the crust the decompressing
mantle surged and seethed
swelling at the basin causing the
weakened crust to bend
buckle and slip beneath into the
underlying
turbulence the thin plate is dragged
across the surface
and into the depths and is replaced with
new crust
erupting from the vents these episodes
of ephemeral subduction
last no more than 10 million years but
they may have instigated the modern
phase
of plate tectonics
on the surface of mars too we see the
results of destructive visitors
across the southern hemisphere the
highlands break suddenly
into yawning cavities with distant rims
in the north though are quiet endless
plains
devoid of landmarks the contrast between
the north and south is stark
and perplexing for many years scientists
pondered this enigma
until detailed topographic mapping
revealed
a titanic ellipse the relic
of a colossal crater covering 42 percent
of the planet so large
as to be almost invisible
the borealis basin
this could mean only one thing
in the deep past a planetoid nearly the
size of pluto hurtled into the north
pole
atomizing itself along with much of the
planet
as thea struck earth so this giant hit
mars the explosion exhumed
half of the martian crust ploughing it
southward in a rolling deluge that
entombed
the rest of the planet in drifts of
rubble possibly
kilometers deep
it is likely that the earth was struck
by several borealis level impacts of its
own
it was inundated with meteors at least
one hundred
000 of which left a crater 20 kilometers
across or larger
some much larger around 3000 the thought
would struck the surface obliterating 25
times their surface area
atomizing and liquefying awful chasms
into the crust
hundreds of meters of ejected material
would have swamped the planet
co-mingling with the sheets of basalt
the earth
churning beneath the chaos under this
deluge
earth's primordial atmosphere would have
been asphyxiated
by vaporized rock condensing into
blazing droplets
of molten rain a global
storm of cinders the heat of which
boiled away
ancient seas the planet would have baked
in
unendurable heat sterilizing the surface
if the first saplings of life survived
this apocalypse
it would have done so hidden within
hydrothermal systems
veins of superheated mineralized fluids
jetting between fractures deep
inside the hellish world
but the borealis basin formed 4.47
billion years ago
long before the era of lunar bombardment
mercury the moon and mars all pockmarked
and pitted by the passage of those
unfortunate bodies that collapsed onto
the earth
however mercury the moon and mars are
unlike earth in many ways
they are small bodies with little
atmosphere and limited geologic activity
they are breathless and still
but venus is akin to earth a
living planet comparable in size and
closest in its orbit to ours
and like the earth venus is still
evolving
but also like the earth its past
experiences are shrouded deep within
layers of elemental cloud
and as yet we can glean no answers
testament from the asteroid belt further
muddies the chronology a bevy of
inter-asteroid impacts between 4.1
and 3.5 billion years ago
could this disruption in the belt
reflect the origin of the bombardment or
its passing through how can we square
this 600 million year period
with the history of lunar bombardment a
sixth
as long what evidence the earth can
provide
tells a similarly confusing story
beds of beads stone raindrops birthed
from the asphyxiated atmosphere after a
major impact
are common as late as 3.5
billion years ago it's clear that the
terrestrial planets were brutally
pounded the question though that is now
being asked
is when
attempts to date the other titanic
impact basins of mars and mercury output
ages that corroborate
the lunar record around 3.8 to 4.1
billion years
but these dates are based on models tied
to the same apollo samples that first
revealed the late heavy bombardment
the theory therefore balances
precariously on the reliability
of a handful of lunar samples collected
half a century ago
[Music]
so far we have sent six apollo missions
to the moon just 12 travellers
making steps on the surface of another
world
three of those missions apollos 14 16
and 17
returned samples that record evidence of
late
heavy bombardment the furthest distance
between these three landing sites indeed
the furthest distance between
any two apollo missions is only one
thousand
six hundred and seven kilometers barely
further than the distance between the
apollo astronauts training facilities
in houston texas and where they landed
at kennedy space center
in florida though limited by
practicalities
scientists had selected these sites for
the differences
in their cratering apollo 14 at imbrium
basin
apollo 17 at serenitatus basin and
apollo 16
at a heavily cratered highland region
in the 50 years since we have trained
our eyes mechanical and organic upon
these assumptions
crispr imaging of the outcrops sampled
by apollo 16
shows that rather than originating from
local craters the stones in question
flew a thousand kilometers from the
imbrium
impact a diaspora
worse chemical evidence of the apollo 17
samples
suggests they too emigrated from the
same
imbrium basin indeed one way to create
an
unexpected anomaly is to accidentally
date the same event
three times the eager scientists of the
1970s
failed to imagine just how far the
influence of a catastrophic collision
could spread in recent years
these time-stretching revelations have
destabilized the theory
of the late heavy bombardment the end of
the bombardment is clearest evidence
shows that it tapered off between 3.8
and
3.5 billion years ago by the earth's
billionth anniversary
the bombardment had abated the solar
system
was finally modified the beginning of
the bombardment however
retains its mystery though there is
little doubt among scientists that
jupiter
was the cause the date of this event
still eludes them some suggest a
chilling explanation
one that has been lurking on the
peripheries of the scientific
discussions
since the seventies what if the glimpse
we have of this catastrophe
is too scant what if we have only
spied its shadow the tortured minerals
scattered across the solar system tell
us their most recent trauma
but they have forgotten their deep past
their crystalline memories wiped
impacts devour digest
remake is it possible that buried
beneath the lunar surface
is a brutal history clawing all the way
back to there
to genesis not a brief apocalypse
no calm before the storm simply storm
all the way down so deeply buried
we cannot yet peer through to it
scrambling for reliable physical
evidence
scientists are coming to the conclusion
that this bombardment
may well not have been late or indeed
heavy but a constant battering
lasting eons
in 2024 for the first time in 50 years
nasa intends to land astronauts once
more
on the moon this time at the lunar south
pole
will they find evidence to corroborate
the late heavy bombardment
or to disprove it rocks showing the same
timestamp as those first examined 50
years ago
or a new brutal billion-year
time span what earth-shattering
revelations
will be revealed this time around
next time we dive deep into the first
oceans of our world
we investigate the tremendous tectonic
forces that reshaped and made the earth
and finally still billions of years in
the primordial past
the very first saplings of life
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like
subscribe and share and let us know in
the comments what you'd like to see
covered
in the future thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time